when you think Back 40 years to Greece
what's the first thing that comes to
mind Olivia
it's my favorite thing about doing
Grease
and you were really instrumental I hear
in actually getting uh Olivia cast right
getting there was utterly no one else
I mean because if you're a young man in
the 70s and I'm sure many of you were
out there if you remember that album
cover of Olivia with that blue shirt on
with those big blue eyes staring right
at you every every boy is every man's
dream was oh I'd love for that girl to
be my girlfriend
so when I had their the privilege to
have input on the casting I said there
is no other person in the universe other
than Olivia and John to play Sandy you
must cast her so I held tight didn't I
yeah and I got my way look at that well
no it definitely